a kindergarten teacher at Nate Mack
Elementary and Henderson got a big
surprise the other day
as family and friends and even
superintendent Dr Jesus Jara gathered in
the hallway outside her classroom Sarah
long had no idea what was about to
happen
Jennifer verado the school district's
director of employee onboarding talked
to Miss Long's young students do you
know that in Clark County School
District we hire over 1 800 new teachers
every year and your team was picked as
the best new teacher of the year
long the best new teacher in the
elementary primary category
superintendent Jara and you are the best
of the best here for us
so miss long and the six other honorees
going to have their pictures on display
at the school district office on
Flamingo near Easton congratulations to
all of them and thanks to all teachers
in all classrooms everywhere we always
want to know what's cool at school you
got something let us know cool at school
under the Community tab of our website
or just email cool at school at
8newsnow.com